all right this is my first video uh for  the new channel sure nobody's really  watching hi mom hi aunt ruth we just hit  100 subscribers like why are any of you  watching my last video why crash  bandicoot is class trader did really  well and i really appreciate the new  popularity which is why i'm going to  immediately monetize hey i just got my  blue yeti i'm so grateful to you guys  committing bank fraud epic just hit the  trending page i'm not sure why the tax  evasion videos are doing so much better  than the minecraft videos but  i'm just going to roll with the  channel's basically becoming my job now  which sucks thank you for making i am  god number one on trending i'm basically  invincible  imagine if i got canceled next week  right to my fans i am truly sorry that  tweet about chuck e cheese and george  soros should have stayed in the drafts  i'm going to take some time off to  reflect and grow as a person  so i made some nfts